you know those co-workers who come to
visit your desk and then you notice that
all your fancy nuts are gone with the
north face avalanche airbag safety
system backpack you can keep the best
nuts for yourself it's the most
dangerous object in the office this
month this backpack lets humans flow to
the surface of an avalanche due to
physics objects with a larger surface
area rise to the top of the shifting
mass even when they're heavier just like
these Brazil nuts so the next time said
co-worker goes for your jar of nuts just
pull the pyrotechnical activation
handler and in three seconds the to
enclose airbags will inflate with 170
litres of nitrogen
you